the Disney plus series Ahsoka is kicked
off with a double lightsaber strike of
episodes full of plot developments and
nods to Star Wars lore here's all the
big stuff and some of the little stuff
too the last viewers saw rather Soaker
and Sabine together was in the finale of
Star Wars Rebels Ezra stayed aboard
thrawn ship to ensure he was defeated
once and for all as he disappeared this
allows the rebel forces to destroy the
command center and carve out a victory
but Ezra is still lost in the wind the
ending sees Sabine and Ahsoka joining
forces to look for Ezra despite how much
of a long shot that is while it's a
hopeful conclusion their relationship
clearly turns sour between Rebels and
Ahsoka after Consulting with Hera Ahsoka
visits Sabine thinking her artist's eye
could help her figure out how to access
the map she secured at the beginning of
the episode Sabine is intrigued but
doesn't want to spend too much time
around Ahsoka so she steals a map and
goes back to a hideout to work on it the
only problem is that Morgan Ellsworth
instructs Shin hearty The Apprentice of
balun skull to travel it's a lothal to
get the map Ahsoka Turk sabine's
lightsaber skills are Rusty and shin is
far too powerful not only does Shin
manage to get the map from her she deals
a nasty blow to sabine's stomach
severely wounding her luckily Sabine
survives the attack and recovers in a
medical center
so B manages to figure out that the map
depicts a pathway between two points but
she doesn't get a good look at what
those two points are before Shin attacks
more information comes to light when
Shin Balan and Morgan ellsbeth visit a
site designed by an ancient people from
a distant Galaxy they look at an
enlarged version of the map that's
Sabine saw a pathway connects one galaxy
to another and the destination is Grand
Amaral thrawn's whereabouts thrawn's
return has long been teased he didn't
exactly die at the end of rebels and
he's been brought up a couple of times
in the Mandalorian Ahsoka seeks
information about him in Chapter 13 the
Jedi and his name comes up again in
chapter 23 the spies when moff Gideon
meets with a shadow Council Grand
thrawn's return will Herald in the
re-emergence of our military
thrawn's return to the galaxy has been
heavily sought with the word War coming
up repeatedly throughout the first two
episodes of Ahsoka remnants of the
Empire remain and this will surely play
a role in the eventual Revival of
Emperor Palpatine and the rise of the
first order but what role will thrawn
play in all of this that remains to be
seen as Baylor mentions of Perth Ford is
clouded it'll take more work for anyone
to travel to thrawn and Ezra's
coordinates and Ahsoka is hot on their
Trail despite losing the map Ahsoka
isn't going down without a fight while
Sabine recovers Ahsoka and hero travel
to corellia but one of the droids came
from fans likely recall corellia is a
home planet of Han Solo it's a shipyard
for the new Republic after the fall of
the Empire which makes the presence of
such a Droid suspect all Imperial
technology should have been dismantled
but the Rebellion didn't succeed in
wiping out the Empire completely Ahsoka
and Hera get a good deal of dubious
information from Min Weaver who
discusses how Imperial assets were taken
in by the Republic and those who worked
for the Empire now work for them this
clearly doesn't sit well with us so as a
question former Imperials loyalty their
suspicions are confirmed and they're
attached or trying to prevent a
transport carrying a HK class Droid from
departing the ship gets away but not
before Hera and Chopper managed to get a
tracking device on it the sequel Trilogy
established as a first order as a new
threat and the second episode of Ahsoka
provides a trail of crumbs showing how
these nefarious forces were able to
regain power so quickly their loyalty
doesn't merely extend to whoever's
paying them numerous people work behind
the scenes to circumvent the new
Republic
it's not loyalty
it's greed
the new Republic assuming former
Imperials would fall into line will
prove to be its undoing the machinations
that will allow Morgan Elle's best to
reach thrawn are already underway and
when she checks in with the balun and
shin she reveals how the installation of
the final hyperdrive is currently in the
works muntis completes the eye of Siam
will allow Morgan and the other
antagonists to reach thrawn this ties
into the scenes on corellia while the
Republic wanted to use Imperial
technology for its own uses the fact
people still loyal to the Empire
continue to work on it men Morgan could
still acquire what she needed
fortunately Ahsoka and the team aren't
giving up that easily who Yang informs
them how the that had a Tracker
place on it ended up in the den up
system that ship was carrying a
hyperdrive core which is likely what
Morgan needed to finish a ship the bad
guys may have what they need to reach
their goals but to reunited Ahsoka and
Sabine are on the way throughout the
first two episodes of Ahsoka this
animosity between Ahsoka and Sabine but
Sabine appears to let go of the past to
move forward and try to rescue Ezra at
the end of episode 2 Sabine cuts off her
hair puts on her Mandalorian armor and
joins Ahsoka in a quest of the den up
system Ahsoka even refers to sabina's
Padawan the Jedi term for an apprentice
savine is well acquainted with padawans
Ezra studied under Kane and Jairus and
Star Wars Rebels she wielded a
lightsaber in a fight against Shin but
the Harley means she could be considered
a force user throughout Star Wars Rebels
Sabine is around several forced users
that never demonstrates the ability
herself and she's passy Adria most
become aware of their powers they're
still evidence from Star Wars Rebels and
other properties that Sabine could be
Force sensitive though Ahsoka is just
getting started after all now that we've
covered the major plot points we can get
to some of those sneaky Easter eggs
throughout the episode right off the bat
there's a black tinted 3PO unit on the
ship transport in Morgan ellsbeth this
protocol Droid gets a frankly
disproportionate amount of love from the
camera even after it gets destroyed
huyanka's appointed look at its wrecked
torso the droid's distinctive paint job
is clearly and not the triple zero the
pitch black torture Droid hails from the
Star Wars comics combining c3po's
verbosity and unassuming appearance with
a mind of an unrepentant sadist
naturally the Droid tends to hang out
with the equally villainous R2D2
lookalike bt-1 it's unlikely that this
particular black 3PO unit we see a
master and Apprentice will gain a pair
of red eyes and become triple zero but
the visual similarities seems to be no
accident in the Clone Wars Ahsoka was
known to use her lightsabers to create
improvised entrances in the floral
ceiling by the time of Ahsoka she's
honed this skill into an art form an
early cool moment in the series premiere
features Ahsoka using the force to spin
her lightsabers around her cutting a
hole in the ground in order to enter a
hidden chamber the moment serves as a
clear callback to the Clone Wars but as
it turns out it's just the beginning
when enemy droids turn up and challenge
her for the map she just obtained she
bursts out the move again by jumping
back into the chamber and literally in
the mining multiple opponents by spin
cutting the floor from underneath their
feet the smirk on her face just before
she pulls this off reveals what a huge
Flex this is it seems that she's just
delighted to find an excuse to use her
classic trick from the animated series
The Mood takes a sudden turn when home
one contacts ahsoka's ship to deliver
the news that Morgan Ellsworth has
escaped there's also a moment of huge
significance to fans of the Star Wars
animated series when huyang answers home
one's call and mentions ahsoka's code
name come in no one this is fulcrum over
fulcrum is a designation of an important
and influential faction of Rebel agents
who contributed heavily to toppling the
Empire their ranks have included
heavyweights like Cassie and Andor as it
happens Ahsoka is the creator of the
fulcrum system and the most prominent
agent to use a moniker so it's both
incredibly cool and extremely fitting
that the title lives on as a cool sign
when Governor Ryder assadi gives us big
speech on lothal there's a weirdly
cartoonish mural in the background it's
seen even more clearly in the second
episode when Sabine looks at it rights
after cutting her hair it's our style
clashes with basically everything we've
seen in live action Star Wars but that's
the point isn't it this work of art is
quite possibly the most obvious nod to
the fact that Ahsoka owes everything to
the animated shows that came before it
known as the specter's mural Sabine Ren
painted this mural of the titular Squad
near the end of Star Wars Rebels and
visited it just before embarking on a
journey to find Ezra Bridger with Ahsoka
the murals Rebels accurate appearance in
Ahsoka essentially confirms that the
show isn't hiding its roots that's made
even more clear when ahsoka's T6 Jedi
shuttle flies over sabine's Tower in a
nearly shot perfect Recreation of a
moment from the final episode of rebels
in the Mandalorian Morgan ellsbeth rules
the city of kaladan as his magistrate
and she's surprisingly tough armed with
little more than an attitude and some
serious skills are the best car spear
she puts up a decent fight in the
climactic samurai style Showdown with
Ahsoka the first episode of Ahsoka
reveals that she's more than just
strawn's old lucky she casually mentions
that she's also one of the ninth sisters
of dathomir you're a witch oh
a survivor
this powerful group of dark force users
was an ominous presence in the Clone
Wars though they seem to be largely
extinct by the time Ahsoka takes place
still the offhand Revelation that the
former magistrate is a member of this
ancient sect is a nice little addition
that serves to further connect the
animated Star Wars shows and the
live-action ones after Sabine is injured
Ahsoka visits sabine's home to get more
information Ahsoka here is a drawing of
lightsabers and the two women speaking
to each other this power goes by many
names in Star Wars but most probably
know it as a force Echo it's also been
called senseico psychometry and
retrocognition this is a force ability
that allows the users to obtain
information about events or people to a
location or object in this instance
Ahsoka is able to hear what happened
drawings have been in Shin's fight the
force Echo has a history in the Star
Wars Legends timeline which Disney and
canonized when it pursued news stories
for film and television however aspects
of Legends have made their way into new
stories and the force Echo was
officially re-established in Star Wars
lore within the hunt for zero episode of
the Clone Wars many will likely we know
about the full set go from the Jedi
Fallen order and Jedi Survivor video
games as well after realizing how much
he needs Ahsoka Sabine heads back home
and takes out a Mandalorian armor Star
Wars Rebels establishes Osama is over
500 years old but Sabine naturally puts
her own spin on it ever the artists are
being colored various plays with bright
vibrant colors making them uniquely her
own one pauldron Bears a rebel a lion
starbird logo the other should be a
delight for anyone who watched Rebels
throughout the Animated Series Sabine
painted various animals on her left
pauldron the final battle with thrawn
features per girl essentially space
whales I can leap through hyperspace
taking thrawn Star Destroyer away to
unknown regions with Ezra on board the
final moments of rebels reveal that
Sabine is painted a per Gill on that
pauldron it seems like she hasn't
changed it in the years since
potentially demonstrating how Sabine
turned her back on the Mandalorian way
for a long time to head into a dangerous
future she must done the armor once more